absolutely yes I'd love to see your
answers yeah you just was never a
pursuit my first video was it was David
Choi holding a his laptop and being like
you gotta be on YouTube
that's not how he's not an old man I
know I made noise it was just a great
way to get your songs out there and get
some feedback and I fell in love with it
there's a bit of an ego boost when
you're online you get some comments and
good feedback you're like awesome cool
and that kind of evolved as as YouTube
evolved it became more about creating
something really innovative for the
space and because it became a business
and it has with the ad revenue that you
can generate I think concentrators does
it have a ball too but you have to be
careful with how you evolve cuz I think
you have to keep in mind Freddie Wong
brought this up not too long ago it you
really don't want to start focusing your
content on views or what you think is
gonna be the best way to get views or
report capitalize on a hot moment like
really still at the end of the day has
we planted even want to create that you
were bashing like creating and I hope
that I'm still doing that
I'd be lying if I said I have to check
myself every once a lot alike cuz he
behind the season with you how am I
gonna get that SEO and I can't have like
I got to do the next hit thing I gotta
make sure that I'm still having fun it's
very common to fall for your friend and
realize whoa whoa we have such a good
thing going like just gonna ruin it and
if they're not if it's not reciprocal
then you know that can cause problems
and you you start weighing that should I
even speak up kind of thing I was going
through yeah and so I feel like that's a
relatable song for a lot of my fans
Utley says how it comes off outside of
all the other like how did this happen
to you which is flattering but yeah 90%
of my love songs are about how I didn't
get the girl huh
so Antoine I'm like most emotionally
charged I think has why I write so many
I think you know when you when you
follow a mainstream artists you're
following them as this perception of
them and it's not nearly as real yeah
and you only see them in that light
there on a pedestal so speaking then in
their little untouchable
whereas in the Han lines artist you
constantly see them in the real
environment and because of the vlogging
and the talking directly to camera in
the comment and you really get to
interact with that person you feel like
you have to know her I did this with
Julian Smith
I love Julian Smith's work because I'm
about a year and a half two years ago
and I was at Whole Foods and I saw him I
was like Julian literally as if we're
friends it's like Julian instantly
realized I don't know this guy I've only
watched his videos and he was like hey
and I was like gee you I love your
videos I see your videos and I was like
federating joining some money myself
and he's like oh thanks like I was like
IU IU - I was like literally stuttering
I was like fangirl cause like I YouTube
- and then he introduced me to his wife
he was really kind of nice like I assume
yeah I walked away like I am literally
fangirling over you - right now and I
thought I knew him when I saw so I get I
really
I had a peel box for a while and need to
be over that some somebody just kept
sending me old VHS tapes of Star Trek
like with no explanation like not even
like hey you look like one of the
characters and scenes nothing like no
just kept getting the VHS tapes
interject and envelopes with dirt you
know men not a lot it was like like he
went like it was just with no again no
explanation I'm looking right now I
think that's why I'm struggling a doing
this I'm not doing anything and I'm just
working I'm married to my work right now
I guess that's lame how lame do I sound
yeah a little bit it's so loud so
crowded and sweaty and ha and you're
like it's fun for a second and then it's
instantly like 20 minutes into the end
the club I'm like this is great let's
you gotta go eat early like I don't know
how to I don't understand really why
it's so much fun really well it's
ridiculous in those clubs when I was in
college it was more than I could were
very leery ated and it wasn't about
conversation I don't know I don't know
it wasn't a different mindset back then
maybe I'm just laying now I'm so lame
now here's perfect Friday night is I'm
married I have a young a kid and I we're
gonna go see a Disney movie I don't know
I'm going this but my point is that
would be way more fun if I was already
married had a kid I want to be married
know what come on my kid and a garage
I'm a garage I'd love to settle down
yeah I'm into that I feel like it would
change things for the better that sounds
horrible I could not want a kid just in
case I mean that I see my friends that
have kids and it just seems like they're
he just gives her life a little bit
there's different purpose there I want
that it's thumbs nice I still have a
crush on Tom Cruise is that weird a man
crush on how weird I we gave him such a
hard time in like mid 2000 or whatever
you call those that
Oh 506 SME I get it but I just love his
work and I was excited about the next
thing Oblivion you're gonna see a live
in
oh speaking of movies and don't need
none of my ADHD here but I Gerard Butler
in a lipid has fallen might be the best
action you have seen since I don't know
the 90s I loved it it's die hard meets
the White House it's great
you
a couple things and I don't want to
quote spider-man but that you do have a
responsibility when you when you become
influential it's hard to read all the
messages now but I used to read all the
messages you know and I still read a lot
of them but I used to read every single
message when we first started most six
or seven or eight men and a lot of those
messages were just people venting just
literally just also I became their
friend and they were just like hey my
mom has cancer
and ball oh well this is my day not even
asking for advice just being like this
is what's happening in my life in the
messages that's it and I got a lot man I
didn't get a lot of people saying thank
you for your music and music has helped
me through this time that time oh my god
and it just it just it sometimes put
things it puts things in perspective
like how well we have it off I say we've
disabused I think just being alive
living in the States and the
opportunities that we have or just
already I feel like I'm less in the one
person and and these kids all around the
world like going through their hardship
comes from serious hardships it just it
maybe it made me realize that everybody
is going through something like everyone
is dealing with their stuff and life can
be hard for everyone so this actually
went through a stage I was reading a lot
of songs that were about that so I try
to keep that in mind I guess you know
just remind myself how lucky I am to be
where I am right now there are certain
negative comments you shouldn't stand up
and speak out to and I just did this but
before you guys got here there was a
comment that said you know there's a
million things wrong with being gay
that's not a message that I would want
anywhere so I I know I responded back
with you you should probably unsubscribe
and find someone else to watch take care
buddy
we're so cautious of what we say and
we're trying to be politically correct
but if you actually do stand for
something and you actually do believe in
something I think it is your right I
mean I think it's your responsibility to
speak up I feel like I'm not being true
to yourself if you don't speak up if you
actually truly believe in something and
you're not using this amazing
opportunity that you have because you're
in
to online you have access to these eyes
and ears and you're not gonna take that
moment to help convey your message like
I think you're you're dropping the ball
so when it comes to things like that you
should speak up but but the the nonsense
stuff like you know wow you suck my ears
are bleeding like yeah whatever I mean I
don't you got a dis ignore that kind of
stuff YouTube's on top of the commenting
thing by the way they're helping out
they're gonna got some things in the
works I believe so I hear right now we
tend to look at YouTube as a stepping
stone to something else still I mean we
it's a place of awareness for a lot of
people but we're the jvc is not really
attached to a lot of the online
influencers just yet although I should I
think the biggest issue is that we don't
we don't get the same sort of marketing
power and marketing is everything I mean
you look at the show as an additional
world and whether or not you see madman
you know what Mad Men is I've never seen
Mad Men but I know what it is why could
they spend millions millions of dollars
on PA marketing money
there's billboards and posters it's an
articles and it's talked about and that
in itself creates a brand that is worth
something they pay for a higher quality
brand just by marketing it it's so
oversaturated online there's so much
content being created there's some great
stuff but nothing is getting the same
kind of support
there's no spotlight on something right
now the reason everyone is so concerned
with treating the Internet at least song
for the better quality higher content
stuff like an IP machine where you can
take something and you can sell it
upstream or you that's still a big
strategy and people could stuff online
for this low budget because that's where
the the real revenue is gonna be the
economics don't make sense online when
you try to create something on a bigger
budget and you're trying to make your
money back on the ad revenue because
it's just not there she's not there yet
and until we actually create the right
perception well what we're doing online
so that the brand's can see ok this is
not user generated content that you can
trust this is high quality stuff it's
consistent it's it's similar to what
we're used to paying for in their
additional world when that happens I
think we'll see some of those rates go
up and we'll be able to make sense of
what's going on online for creating
content and making money from the
right there I do see it happening but
again we need some bigger success
stories we need some real success
stories online if I were you two I'd
probably pick a few I predict a few
content creators and projects that are
online and really market the hell out of
it and and see what happens because I'd
be curious to see how quickly a Daily
Grace becomes a household name if we
support her like a traditional star the
other thing that's very confusing to me
is that you know the network world you
know these mineral channels they work
off the Nielsen system which is I mean
how much information they're really
getting from the Nielsen system and I
mean how many times you watch a TV show
and like they keep trying to sell me
tampons like I don't want to meet an
appliance like you guys I don't think
it's smart advertising and when you have
someone's IP address and you have access
to what they're searching you can fine
tune those ads and I mean really raise
the conversion of beer at a consumer
that's a better place to sell why are
the rates so far off if I'm in the
market for a car show me some freaking
car pad if I'm in the market for a suit
you owe me some soon as like I'd like to
see those ads now I'm actually
interested in your freaking ad you know
like but when you're showing me
something that has nothing to do with
anything then I want I can't wait to hit
skip in five seconds hey guys thanks for
checking out that interview you can
check out the full written interview and
the photoshoot on new media rockstars so
make sure to LIKE subscribe favorite
share this up I have the blast I had a
blast
I haven't stirred something I had a
blast it was a lot of fun see you guys
in the interwebs I was really excited as
I start wearing these cycles all the
time but I didn't know that the point is
to actually clip it to the shirt so I
always rocking tie clips like an
accessory being like yeah but it's
actually served a purpose like yeah
actually this is was to keep the tie for
me